Let's talk a bit more about the Course Forum.
We use Piazza to host our Georgia Tech OMS
course forums. Let's walk through it together. You can
access your courses from the drop down menu here. On
the left hand side, are posts from your instructors
and classmates. Instructor posts will be marked with this
little orange-yellow square. Forums are the best place to
go to meet your fellow classmates, engage in discussion, and
ask questions to the TA and instructor. Feel free to check
out piazza.com to see demos and tutorials on how to use
the forum software. For the purposes of this orientation, I'm just
going to quickly walk you through how to create a new post.
All you do is click the New Post button. From here
you can select the type of post that it is. You
can choose from a question that you want someone to answer,
a note if you're just sharing or commenting on something, or
even a poll or in class response from your
peers. You can see that you have the option to
either post to the entire class, or only to
the instructors. You can even select which instructors that you
want to post to. Finally, you can choose a
folder or tag to include your post in, depending on
the nature of the post. You'll then enter a one
line summary of 100 characters or less, that describes what
the post is about. The one line summaries will
show up here, in bold, on top of your post.